[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
[Music]
the fire is
[Music]
eyes for your eyes
[Music]
think about it later
[Music]
think about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
now anyone can learn the magnus trainer
app is packed with fun mini games and
interactive training content
playable anytime anywhere get the magnus
trainer
available in the app store and google
play
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're a chess player you have plenty
of opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chessable masters
super tournament
don't miss the opportunity to learn from
the best
check out the chess 24 shows area and
tune in for banter blitzes with the
likes of magnus carlsen
fabiano carawana alexander krischuk
and pentala harry krishna go premium at
chess24 to challenge them
and gain full access to the world's most
entertaining chess platform
[Music]
welcome magnus enjoying the action
uh oh yeah absolutely it's been
pretty well there's been significant
action haven't seen
anything close to the last of it
uh gf played and uh yeah uh tamer yeah
has three seconds but he has been doing
this his entire life
g3 is gone yeah baby
what a move yeah no
it really is very very nice to see him
back at this oh yeah
i mean regardless of what happens in the
game this is awesome
true
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
after queen d1 which is a mistake now we
have discovered
uh e6 was a very strong move for nepali
as she opens up the diagonal of the
queen and at the same time
shuts out the d5 bishop from the defense
black has to play rookie seven to
protect the
corn and the seventh rank but now the
queen comes from the f5 queen f2
threatening rook f7 and its
curtains so the position is collapsing
right now here black has to resign
what happened in the game shows why e6
was so powerful but let
that led me to the conclusion that
queen d1 is a mistake because it allows
e6 so the correct move for black
as sad as the position is rookie six
perhaps
could still try to hold i do think that
white has an advantage quite a big
advantage possibly but at least it's
not an immediate resignation black still
has a fighting chance in the game so
stopping the pawn from being pushed to
e6
was crucial for black and as the arrow
shows that peter is really good at
drawing ariel's
the air pulse pawn could give some kind
of a counter play for black in case
white doesn't play the most precise the
most forceful moves so
good learning moment for us that the
pawn on e5
had to be stopped once it landed on e6
the game was over for the world number
two fabiano caruana
[Music]
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess mastery
magnus carlsen introduces chessable the
definitive solution
for studying chess movetrainer uses the
science of space repetition
to identify your strengths and eliminate
your weaknesses
there's no need to set up a board
remember which page you're on or keep
track of all the moves you miss move
trainer empowers you to go from the
opening to the end game with confidence
it's a seamless effective and fun way to
study chess
choose from one of the largest online
chess libraries in the world
with hundreds of titles ranging from
classic books
through to our exclusive chessable
courses
including over 100 free courses
expert insights from international
master john bartholomew
grand master sam shackling international
master christoph zilecki grandmaster
simon williams
world champion magnus carlsen and
hundreds of other instructors
get started now and join our growing
community of over 100 000
chess enthusiasts at chesable.com
chesable take control of your journey
towards chess
mastery hello everyone and welcome to
the chessable masters
as we are in the business end of things
in the quarter finals the preliminaries
have been played and four participants
have sadly made their exit
i'm your host jessica irwin and along
with two other wonderful presenters
anna rudolph is taking care of all of
our social media platforms
and chess 24's very own
analyst extraordinaire peter spidler is
with us
a big welcome to you both and hello anna
hello yes sir and hello everybody tuning
in on twitch youtube and
chess24 welcome everybody to the first
bit
of the quarterfinals as yasser said we
unfortunately had to say favor to four
players but the remainder of the field
is stellar too i can't wait to cover
today's action and i'll be monitoring
all three chats on twitch on youtube and
chess24 as well as
our hashtag on twitter studychest make
sure to use it
to get in touch with us and i'll later
on show you
the question of the day but on that note
i must say
it's a very hot day in ireland how are
you feeling about
these hot days peter in russia
too yeah i'm i'm literally melting here
it's uh
it's been a challenging day already i
had to go outside for 10 minutes to pick
up
a book for one of my kids and uh
i regretted it instantly he can go
without books from now on
i must say both of you are heroes since
you are wearing a proper jacket
suit i'm just here like this is summer
and i'm allowed to
look like it's summer we may want to
join you anna i'm telling you it is very
very hot here in
holland as well uh we're in the 30s what
might even be called tropical weather
over here where
we're melting if the suit jacket does
come off
i'm apologizing in advance as i said
we're in the quarterfinals the four
players who have exited the tournament
each uh left with four thousand dollars
so it wasn't all together bad it's a
hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in this the
third leg of the magnus carlson
one million dollar tour and i've always
said for the good of chess i should be a
millionaire
and this is a way to do it uh as you see
uh the players four players will be
exiting this
stage of the competition the
quarterfinals and they will walk away
with eight thousand dollars nobody wants
to walk away with eight thousand dollars
they want to stay in the competition uh
this is the first of
five days of quarter-final competition
the idea is that on each day they'll
play
four rapid games actually that's a
little bit untrue
their goal is to score two and a half in
the rapid games if they do that in the
first three games the fourth game is not
needed
uh they'll do that for three days
and the idea is you need to win two of
the three days
if after four rapid games the match is
tied to
two we play a pair of blitz games
uh five minutes and three minutes and if
the match remains tied
we'll play one armageddon game
for the quarterfinals the drawing is
pretty simple
the number one seed in one group plays
the number four
uh seed uh from the other
group the players who are highest seeds
have the right to choose the colors
in both the first game as well as in any
armageddon games that
may be played so it was very good for
those people who played very well in the
preliminaries
to be high seeds and as we get prepared
for this again the quarterfinals keep in
mind
four players will be playing today they
have a pair
they pair off against each other and
these are knockout matches tomorrow
another pair of players will join
but at this point i would like to turn
it over to peter
to introduce the knockout quarterfinals
peter what do you think of our pairings
yeah we have two very intriguing
uh matches today uh the first sets of uh
the match between
uh magnus and fabi who are uh
obviously uh two players who know each
other quite well having played a world
championship match against each other in
2018
uh and they've played up a number of
very interesting encounters since of
course
and the old russian quarterfinal of
artemia versus nipomnishi
to uh two players of i think contrasting
styles but
both of them are very very strong
uh very uh efficient uh online players
as well
uh a good online pedigree and
uh good both of those could become quite
explosive i think
uh if we talk about the uh the carlson
karana match which
uh even for me as a as a russian i do i
do feel like
uh i'm probably looking forward to that
one more
uh but that's i think
influenced quite a lot by
their recent clutch chess final
because generally uh games within
worlds number one and two they do
tend to be on the dry side but in the
clutch finals
uh it seemed as if they they made some
kind of an unspoken agreement to not
play boring openings
and and there was a tremendous amount of
bloodshed
uh pretty much every single game was
immensely exciting and uh the
uh the uh drama
uh and the way the match ended were
really
uh absolutely fantastic to watch so uh
if
if we get to to see something along
those lines it will really be a treat
for
for any chess lover a match for the ages
to be sure and i did
actually call those clutch matches and
boy you are absolutely right peter
it was a drama for the ages which
brings the question uh in the chess
fantasy
uh how are we all doing uh anna
i'm afraid we are not doing very well
but this is a good reminder for our
viewers that we have a new fantasy
bracket
for today so in order to participate in
our fantasy chess contest you need to
fill out the bracket
before today's first game begins head
over to chess 24
if you want to have a chance at winning
our apple ipad or amazon fire hd
10. i'm hoping that peter and i will do
better for the rest of the event because
what you see in the standings among our
staff
um i'm lost with four points and peter
has
six points so far yeah group b
was not kind to me and uh and and anna
we just got i think pretty much
all we could have gotten wrong uh wrong
in group b and uh
uh that uh resulted in a complete
blowout but i am very happy for the man
on the horse who is
uh leading the the ffl fantasy
competition
shout out to mr dodgy the man on the
horse
and also on that note uh we do have a
segment on what have the players been up
to
on their free day starting with the
winner of
group b anish giri he posted this on his
instagram a lovely family portrait
from the beach apparently it was 29
degrees celsius
in the hague the bichops heaven ingen
the opening chevening and is named after
a beach in the netherlands
which was their place of visit i believe
and the next image is also from anish's
instagram
his instagram story of how he's
preparing for his
match that's gonna be tomorrow against
alexander grisham if we could move on to
the next slide
this is anish's instagram story
preparing
for the match against the three-time
world bliss champion alexander grishouk
with his second daniel geary three and a
half years
old moving on to the next slide we have
daniel dubov who unfortunately is not
competing with us anymore he steadily
had to say goodbye from group a but he
did play a banter blitz session
yesterday if we could bring up that
tweet from chesterball
he played against chess 24 premier
members yesterday and also
solved checkmates on chessable which
will be a video coming up shortly
for you dear viewers another player
stellar player that had a banter
recession yesterday is dingley ran
he played on chess 24 as well as a
chinese platform where grandmaster lee
chell was covering his games with over
000 viewers tuning in to the session
of dingley ren in china thank you so
much ayala
for the tweet the next one is from hari
krishna who
sadly also had to say goodbye to this
event but he is very active on chastivo
and he is practicing with the chanceable
course
which is based on this event so if you
didn't know there's a free course on
chastity
about this event and the tactic you see
on the board
was one of the missed moments of the
event hari krishna vs carson
try to solve the tactics if you did not
see it in our coverage
and our final one from yesterday's three
days of course
magnus carlsen who said it's a
goddamn difficult to update his status
constantly and i believe that does not
refer to his world number one spot nor
the world champions title
but his fantasy chess
ranking very important absolutely
uh fantasy football but uh it isn't
fantasy oh sorry fantasy football did i
say fantasy chess
oh i'm too focused on our fantasy chess
but fantasy football the world champion
is doing once again very well in fantasy
football
thank you for that anna and seriously on
that note where
the uh chess 24 premier members get a
chance to play
banner chess with our great players
there's also a possibility of how they
can become
premier members through our question of
the day what is today's
question of the day if we bring up our
slide of
the question of the day it is what makes
chess
such a rich past time and sport use the
hashtag
studychat on twitter if you would like
to win the course of the day which we
will announce later on but this is the
question
answer on twitter by using the hashtag
studychest and our previous winner
was that the
tweet from the previous day it was
flopsy tweeting i would love to have
paul borta as my coach because his own
dubious opinion of his prep would
justify my belief
that the proper reply to 1d4 is the
king's indian
at which point we can just move on to
hearthstone and poker advice
i think this tweet was especially a
candidate since peter said on the
broadcast
i'm sure this tweet will not win
nice this is all a conspiracy to make me
feel bad about every single opinion i
express
never never peter we so appreciate your
opinion
nice i i like it a lot i i tell you
those
premier memberships i think we should be
far more generous
in terms of giving them out because uh
really there's been some marvelous
uh tweets and one i in particular
i like uh way back uh i think it was
like day one or two of the preliminaries
and it was somebody
maker made a reference to hulk and when
i grew up as a teen
i absolutely loved the marvel comic
books and certainly
hulk was one of my favorites uh
peter did you ever get into any of the
marvel comic books
not not a lot this definitely wasn't you
know
a part of me growing up because uh
my childhood is still you know i still
lived in the soviet union then and uh
there wasn't a lot of uh cultural
culture cultural exchange in particular
like i'm sure some people had access to
comics but not
not the the general population uh
i have uh started at some point
uh trying to educate myself on that
topic like i have a
bit and then was very happy to pass on
to my kids but
not the not a huge collection and i i
don't consider myself a specialist oh
pity my favorite of course was the
silver surfer
uh the man with the cosmic energy
and i'll tell you what a challenge to
our audience uh you come up with a tweet
that connects silver surfer the
chessable masters
and chess 24 in a tweet i'll make sure
you get
a premiere a member to chess24
wow a special yes surprise yes exactly
i'll make sure it happens
uh and uh talking about
uh special prizes back to you anna
for social media prizes thank you yes
sir of course
since we have already mentioned the
updates from the free day what we will
now focus on is what's going to happen
today
and the big news is that we have carlson
versus corona
again it's about this match starting
with
magnus cousins tweet from before the
event when he said
i found the clutch referring to the
event in saint louis
but who is the most chasticable this was
his tweet about the event since then
he won group a and will now face karana
who tweeted
about the pairings simply the word
rematch
exclamation mark hashtag study chess
i tweeted today about this match of
course because i had
the pleasure of commentating on the
world chess championship match in 2018
with the one and only judith pogar in
london
and i also want to add to this picture
that the face mask that we are holding
was from a chessable event chastobo
hosted
a blitz tournament in london on one of
the free days and all the participants
of the blitz event
had to wear either a cousin or carry a
face mask
imagine playing on someone who looks
like carina who looks like carlson
you had to pick the one that you were
rooting for in
london and our final post is once again
from the world champion preparing for
today's
game against fabiano today's mini match
with his
second peter heine at a different sport
before we discuss magnus's basketball
skills i think we could
sum up the world championship match and
clutch chest since these were the two
main matches that magnus section there
left peter exposed to an open shot
very nicely done very nicely done magnus
all right uh seriously this has been a
this is going to be a very very exciting
uh
quarterfinals um
how peter uh magnus
in 2018 the world championship match 12
draws as we all know
credited fabiano as improving a great
deal
in his rapid chess skills and said that
the clutch chest match
could go either way what do you see
as the determinant factors for this
match today
i think as often
when when two players of
closely matched closely matched players
uh play against each other i think
form on the day is is often the deciding
factor
[Music]
magnus does i believe start as a
favorite pretty much
whoever he plays if he's playing well
but
um as both of us have already spoken
uh off earlier brilliantly in it he went
one down more than once i think in the
match and and
and and struck back almost immediately
uh
they did seem to be just trading blows
uh throughout the 12-12 game
uh contest uh resulting
at the very end by by far between game
11 and then magnus winning
game 12 on demand to to win by
one easily point in the end uh
but i i don't really expect
neither uh or of these two guys to to do
anything
outlandish uh but uh
even within their normal opening
repertoire there are
more solid things and less solid things
and uh
in in that in that uh clutch final they
were
consistently aiming for the most
fighting the most unbalanced positions
they could
in a very very uh uh unbalanced
situation so
if they continue like that i think uh
all bets are off
yeah a treat indeed uh is in store for
us
is number one and number two in the
classical
ratings uh prepare to do battle
anna let's take a retrospective a little
bit on that world championship
match in 2018. your thoughts please
i think i saw it anyway carlson had
decisive advantage in game one
time pressure and everything he could
ask for
uh but fabfab piano fought hard sweat
blood dodged the bullet
he was quick to recover and out prep
meg game six you believe in fortresses
you believe in fortresses 68 bishop
h4 is six six modules
they had a million at stake the world is
one way to remember
the 1836 that was made by fabiano
and later on after 12 jaws 12
thrilling draws we had a rapid tie break
today's event is in rapid chess so the
question then again is magnus carson
better
at rapid than fabiano if we compare
their skills in classical chess
and rapid what do you think yester this
time control
how does it suit fabiano i think he has
made
a lot of uh great adjustments in fact i
see fabi literally up until the year
2018 is really
concentrating on his classical chess
skills wanting to become the best chess
player that he could be
and let's face it he fought his way to
the world championship match
he went up against magnus carlson the
highest rated player in the world
as you pointed out he missed the mate in
36. i inadvertently thought it was mate
in 32
uh miss counting uh terrible but no
seriously
that was a fantastic match and the
outcome
uh in the tiebreaker was just so
one-sided that
it it kind of snapped that fabby and he
said okay i
understand now my challenge is really a
lot greater than i thought i
i now realize that i really have to
improve myself
in rapid chess and what he did in the
clutch chess match was just
amazing i don't think he could have done
that two years ago i don't think he
could have done it a year ago
so he's done some really really extra
special work
the top players have recognized that
rapid and blitz world championships
are titles that they can aspire to try
to win
and so you're seeing a lot of the top
players uh
really being focused in
their rapid and blitz skills and now hey
you know
online chats uh it's moved online you're
not gonna play
classical chess online so you better be
preparing
uh your blitz and rapid skills
and peter just your thought on that as
well do you think
the players are um getting better
let's just put it like that in blitz and
rapid chess
i think so and i think it's really not
you know very stunning development
because uh
uh the the world rapid english has uh
grown in stature
i think consistently over the years it's
now very much
part of the uh the calendar for every
top player i think
most players try to be there uh most
players
feel like it's a sort of absolutely the
correct way to round off the year those
uh
those five days and generally a lot more
top-level practice that is available to
players which i think is
how people improve even at that level uh
without competitive practice so
you know playing these formats uh
four high stakes against really top
level opposition
is is how you get better uh
and i think uh there's there has already
been a shift in that direction and now
with uh the chess calendar
moving exclusively online pretty much
for obvious reasons
uh people are getting even more
practicing exactly and
uh sorry to interrupt you peter but
in somebody's famous words they're off
and they're off exactly yeah and uh
uh we'll start i guess with the uh with
the carlson corona match where
uh they are very rapidly uh
moving along in the line which kind of
entered the public consciousness i would
say
i want to say maybe five to seven years
ago no that's
that's a bit that's a bit long maybe
five years seven is a bit too much
uh at some point people started playing
this this move order
g4 knight of 64 e6 knight f3 g5
knight g3 a6 this move order and also
just
simply knight c3 a6 on move three too
uh too ambitious but this position
definitely at first glance it looks uh
extremely strange but uh attempts to
refute it outright i think have
uh generally failed right
and these days uh most players with the
white pieces do
uh the kind of a thing that magnus is
doing in this game for instance
uh namely uh they play some kind of a
carlsbad saying that
yes you will have the khalsa they are uh
somewhat better for white in particular
if the bishop on e6 cannot be traded
neither for the light square bishop nor
the knight on f3
so they now have uh you know a very
quiet looking position seemingly but but
definitely the type of position that
magnus enjoys playing i would say
and before we continue with the analysis
i just would like to take the word for a
quick moment
to reassure everybody watching on
youtube and twitch and chess 24 that
we are aware of the issue with the
stream but we are working on fixing it
unfortunately there's an internet
connection problem for where the
production is coming from
so it might be dropping frames we are
working on it and we're gonna solve it
please be patient
and enjoy the games in the meantime back
to you yasser and peter
well thank you for that anna yes uh uh
the challenges of what chess 24 and
chess ball are trying to to overcome
or immense and one of the things i'm
really impressed with
uh peter you could probably even talk to
more about that
than i could is the number of languages
that you can choose from um
uh chess 24 has it i believe in as many
as 10 language a chance to know um
and uh shout out to chess 24 for doing
that i just think it's uh
it's fantastic yeah it's been it's been
steadily grown and growing and it's uh
it's very pleasant uh pleasant to watch
how uh
uh how widely it is now uh covering all
the major events
and uh in this position uh you probably
played infinitely more carlsbad than i
have
over the course of uh over the course of
our respective careers
i'm very happy about the sequence that
happened on the board even though
uh we didn't really get to discuss that
before it appeared on the board
i'm a little bit surprised black didn't
play a5 but i wanted to say
i wanted to say i fully expect magnus to
reply to a5 with queen a3
with the intention i'm pretty anyway and
fabi uh
refused uh this queen trade by playing
queen c7
yeah this uh uh you were talking about
the a7 a6 move on move three
that goes way way way back and i'm for
some reason i'm really associating that
move
more with alakine i don't even know why
i probably saw one of his games the idea
of
uh knight f6 and a6 and bishop e6
especially
i'm associating with uh magnus carlson
of all people so i just thought it was a
a kind of an intriguing psychological
ploy by psychology there in the choices
also i completely concur with you peter
that the move a6 a5 to slow down
or stop the move b2b4
is a move that i would have expected uh
fabi to to have played the fact that he
didn't and allowed b2b4 is a bit
mystifying to begin with
and then the fact that well magnus just
said uh
um i b4 is not going away
i'll go queen a3 and rook fc1
so um thing it's kind of funny but in
some ways
the bishop on e6 is in the way
uh it's developed and that's a good
thing but it's not like it's on an
effective square
and in fact the uh rook on e8 kind of
like there's a traffic jam going on in
black's position and
i'm sure black would like to trade a few
pieces
uh to simplify his challenges
absolutely and i think knife b6 is is
generally played not with the intention
of playing knight b6 c4 which is a
structure change which generally i
believe favors white greatly
right but with the intention of bringing
it over to g6 which is a
very good square i think for that knight
in general it's uh
it covers some important squares and
also very very relevantly for these
structures it creates at least the idea
of playing bhp6 f5
because i think you know black generally
would very much like to trade
uh trade that bishop on e6 for the
bishop on d3
but now after knight b6 has been played
magnus does play b2 before
and that type of play feels to me like
it might be a a little bit too slow if
you imagine black playing knight c8 here
b5 let's say aba b96
it feels to me that the pawn on c6 might
be under sort of more pressure than you
are very
comfortable with here with black
absolutely
it does feel like uh concerned to have
a glaring weakness like that on c6
uh unfairly we've ignored the other
quarterfinal
uh match uh peter shall we have a
look-see
sure uh this one is a spanish but uh
sort of true to former tamiya continues
playing the slightly off-beat spanish's
he played this in the prelims i think he
won a
a reasonably nice game against penta
hare krishna i think that game went
you know they got to the same position
but wirelessly slightly different move
order
uh against harry he played i think a6 d6
which we were told is called the
deferred
uh the deferred steinitz but today he
goes g6 which is a
a very old line which kind of fell out
of fashion but i think it's kind of
regaining popularity right now right
returning top top level chess it's
always
tough to um give the opening
some names but this move in particular
g7 gt6
i really do think i'm on solid ground by
uh
referring that to associate that move
with him
uh from his book uh 200 best games by
vasil smithslav which i think by the way
is an amazing book
uh i don't know if if you ever read it
uh
peter or if it made an influence on you
but for me smithslav
again one of those really undismissed
love and i have recently
uh
mainly i'm mentioning this because i i
do want to say that
uh the book is quite nice i've written a
forward
for uh a book which i think is now uh
going through
republishing it it's not out yet but it
will be out
uh hopefully sometime uh this year by
uh by a russian author who is now
uh living in uh in in southeast asia
uh covering both uh his chess influence
uh
and and his life and it should be a very
interesting uh
addition to the uh the the corpus of
uh books on on smith's love but yeah g6
g6 was uh an early favorite of his
and the game continued c3 a6 bishop a4
d6
d4 bishop d7 castles bishop g7 they they
have actually
gotten to this position in the game
harry christian artemis and i think
harry krishnan played rookie one
young goes with h3 knight f6
uh rookie one castles knight bg2 rookie
eight
and here jan decides to uh not
necessarily simplify but
uh sort of uh
clarify the situation in the center by
playing g5 and then bishop c2
i very much like artemis response here
black generally
uh sort of struggles uh finding work for
that bishop on g7
and if you just trade it for the bishop
on c1 that this idea exists
if white does this uh with the knight
steel on d2
very often black will be extremely happy
to play bishop h6
and just trade those bishops off leaving
themselves
with a very nice bishop on d7 which is
not restricted by their own
pawn structure and uh the position we
have on the board right now uh
looks like this and uh 28b8 is also a
very nice
sort of throwback to some rubinstein
games
uh i think uh uh akiba rubenstein was
uh probably the the first major player
who has shown that
in these types of structures queen queen
g8 b8 with the intention of pushing it
on a7 then perhaps on c5
uh is the way to activate that queen
without really committing to
say some move like c6 or c5 fascinating
position that we will be back with but
we do need to
interrupt unfortunately our stream in
order to fix
the lag issue so we need about 30
seconds to reset the stream please don't
go anywhere
we will be back with a much better
broadcast quality
apologies once again for the issue but
it's a connection problem
in the area where our production comes
from in greece
so it's out of our control but we are
working on the issue
and we will now reset the stream so
please stay with us at 30.